live live. As you guys have probably
heard, Dr. Seuss is no longer going to
be selling six particular books because
of stereotypical pictures of certain
nationalities. And it's a really hot
topic right now. We actually made a meme
and a short video just uh trying to
show you that there are things in our
world right now that are really
disturbing about, you know,
Cardi B being on
uh the Kids Choice Awards and she's
rapping about the most perverted
pornographic, honestly, pornographic
lyrics, pornographic
music videos, and yet she's on the Kids
Choice Network, you know, um Nickelodeon
Kids Choice Awards. M
and to me that's just like wow if this
is going on maybe we should have our
focus you know not to A lot of people
looked at that and they said
um that they thought that we were kind
of justifying Dr. Seuss and the Muppets.
We're not we're not justifying what's
going on.
That was more just a focus on like the
state of the state of the world right
now. What's going on in this world?
It seems like our judgment is under
attack and uh you know we've kind of
thrown that out the window and what's
right is wrong and what's wrong is right
and
woman of the year.
Yeah, it's a confusing time.
Who was it a couple years ago that that
won the teacher of the year awards?
There was a male artist and a female
artist.
Yeah, that was um Nicki Minaj and Lil
Wayne.
And Lil Wayne. Yeah,
teacher of the year.
Teacher, what was it in Florida? Yeah,
they had honored them as teachers in
saying that the kids that pay attention
to them are actually um more influenced
than the teachers that they spend every
single day with because you think about
it those kids are spending every single
day listening to their music. So they
are their teacher.
I've actually read recently that um
younger generations view YouTube and you
know influencers as more influential in
their lives than celebrities. For like
our generation was probably more like
celebrities and you're always oh what
are they doing? But but for the newer
generation it's like no what are these
YouTubers doing? What are the
influencers doing?
Yeah. And it might be because uh a
YouTuber has they're not really confined
to uh I have to say what this entity
will allow me to say, you know, they're
just like, oh, I'm going to rant right
now. Boom. And I'm going to say what I
want to say on camera unfiltered, you
know, and that's more like a an
influential voice because they're not
being told or paid. Maybe not. I mean,
we don't know. They might be being paid
to say certain things. And a lot of
these YouTubers, I mean, I they're
getting famous just from YouTube, but um
they're getting huge endorsement deals.
I mean, people are like sending them
products. I remember a girl that used to
work for us. Um she came and interned
with us for one summer and then she left
and started her own YouTube baking
channel and she got to the level where
baking companies were sending her all
the product just literally begging her
to put it on her table and use the
products, right? Why would they do that?
Why would a baking show, why would a
baking company care about a little
YouTuber and say, "You know what? I'm
going to send you all the flour you need
and all the like stuff like that."
There's no reason unless maybe it has an
influence
and power. I mean, so what company it
is,
right?
You know, just use just use it.
Right. Right.
By the way, this isn't
Put it in the corner.
This is just water here.
Yeah. So, back to the Cat in the Hat. I
mean, this is this is an interesting
subject to me. Um, you know, I I feel
like uh
I I grew up kind of reading these books
and and and I've definitely uh read some
of them to my children and stuff. So, I
was kind of shocked when this this
actually came out.
Yeah. So, I was researching just I
wanted to know what exactly it was in
each book. And I don't know if some of
it's just kind of rumors or blowing out
of proportion. I I didn't really see a
whole lot of pictures of this is in the
book. I heard it like hearsay like in
the uh if I ran a zoo, it says it shows
some like Iranians inside of a cage or
something like that. And but but the
thing about Dr. Seuss is it's like this
fictitious world. So I seen pictures of
what appeared to be monkeys wearing
grass skirts and it calls them Africans
because they're from Africa and that
this was a like a racial illustration or
whatever. Another one was a it was a a
Chinese person and it said a China man
or a China boy. It said two different
ways. I seen it two different ways.
That's why I'm wondering like is some of
this uh blown out of proportion or
something. But it said a China man who
eats with sticks and it shows him
wearing like a rice worker hat and a
robe and the wooden shoes and he's
holding a bowl and he's eating with
chopsticks. Now, to me, and I, you know,
you can say I'm tonedeaf or I'm white
privileged or whatever, but when I see
that picture, it doesn't look like
hatred or racist or stereotype. When I
go to the Chinese restaurant, I see
pictures on the wall that look just like
that.
When I go to me a Mexican restaurant, I
see Mexicans with big old sombrero. It's
culture. I don't understand where where
you draw the line where something is
cultural or is it a racial stereotype. I
actually appreciate the variety when I
go to like an ethnic uh uh restaurant.
It's like I kind of want to see that.
And when I travel around and I go into
different countries, I want to immerse
myself into that culture so that I can
experience that culture and and it's
fun. People dress a little bit
differently. I think the variety adds
interest. I mean, it's like if we keep
going down this road, we're all going to
be wearing white suits and and white
hats,
gray jumpsuits like 1984. Now, when you
go to Mexico and you go to the gift
shop, do you see big sombrero?
Do you when you go to I mean, you
probably do like when you go to China,
you can probably buy in a gift shop this
rice hat,
right?
I mean, are they racist for selling that
type of thing? Um
I trying to think where I was going with
this.
Where's What So, I get where you're
going with the content of the book. I
mean, the Okay, so they showed an image,
but what is the text that's going along
with it? That would be my question is
what is the overall tone of the book?
What is the book trying to say? Because
China
that's probably more of the problem than
just there is an image and it's
depicting culture. I mean we see that
all the time.
If there's an image and it's depicting
culture and the text is very derogatory,
then we know we got a problem. That's
that's I guess my question is what is
the text?
There was a rhyme that said a China man
eats with sticks. A China man who eats
with sticks. But back to the the
cultural image, Raiden from Mortal
Kombat has a big old rice hat and Rya,
the new Disney movie, traditional
cultural Asian garb. Like,
yeah,
I'm I'm confused.
They made it like super stereotypical
with the big old like, you know, Asian
guy that was very cartoonish looking.
Like, no Asian people really look like
that, but they really played up on that
for the sake of the movie. Now, to just
or just to clarify before anybody thinks
we're just ignorant, it was the
publisher themselves who declared that
these things are racist and we're not
going to publish this book anymore. It
was them. So, it's not like cancel
culture.
Somebody else siphoned the public or
something.
But with the Muppets, Disney Plus said
that there were some things that but
they didn't take them down. They
actually still play them on Disney Plus,
but there's a big warning about 18
episodes or whatever that have
I don't know, stereotypical portrayals
of people.
So, was Dr. Seuss known to be a racist
or Theodore Geel the author?
I don't know.
Because I mean, if he was and then you
find that kind of thing in the book,
then it's it lends cause for concern.
Now, there there are pictures before he
wrote books that were like uh World War
II type propaganda type things or
whatever. I mean, you saw that kind of
stuff all the time.
So, that that's exactly where I was
going to go with that. Um, when were
these books written? I mean, were they
right around the World Wars?
Are these that old?
I actually don't even know about when
when these actually came out because
I mean, you you would actually have to
take into consideration if we were at
war with either, you know, Japan or we
were, you know, then there's probably
some propaganda that was pushed out into
our country. M
you know, you look at the old Bugs Bunny
ones and they're running around and
taking out the Nazis and you know, so
um the media has for a long time been
portraying or mispraying, I should say,
um you know, cultural differences and
things. So, uh I don't know if that's
spillover and made it into the book when
they were originally written.
Are they are there those those cartoons
they're putting down or they're still
playing? Yeah, I mean some of them were
Yeah, you can look on YouTube and say
see what banned cartoons are and stuff
like that. And of course they put them
out on YouTube. So I don't know how
banned they really are.
Thank you Anthony for that donation,
brother. Appreciate it so much.
No, thank you. Um, and I did want to, so
I the thing is, like I said, I don't
know if I'm just ignorant white
privilege or whatever, but in the same
picture with the Asian person, right
behind him was this barefoot, redneck,
wearing overalls, a long beard, chewing
the backy, you know, like, should I take
offense to that? Like, should I look at
that and be like, that's offensive to me
because that portrays all white people
as ignorant rednecks, hillbillies. So,
so here's kind of the the thing. I I
think that we need to be sensitive,
especially in today's climate with all
the racial tension that's going on,
right? We we should make an actual
effort forward
to to make sure that we're not, you
know, purposefully in um
you know, making waves or whatever.
Yeah. Throwing gas on the fire. Like, I
think we need to be sensitive to that.
Um, do I think we need to just take out
the syrup off of the counter from, you
know, the the grocery store and this and
that and it's like, yeah, this cancel
culture, where's the end of this?
I mean, it's just getting like going
more and more and more. And I think this
is spawning and fueling hatred between
different groups.
I think it is
rather than saying, okay, we can take
into account this book was written quite
a while ago. Let's learn from this and
moving forward, let's not do this.
Yeah. Which is kind of what the warning
on Disney Plus says. We're gonna leave
this up. Yeah. We're gonna leave this up
so it can be a learning experience and a
conversation.
Yeah.
But like when Coca-Cola is saying
be less white, have you heard about
this?
No.
The whole Coca-Cola company is passing
out these flyers that are telling people
to be less white.
Why? Why is attacking?
I don't know what that means.
Because let me tell you, I mean, we're
talking about I mean, we didn't talk
about this, but like the anime from
Little Life Studios. I mean, we have a
Mexican persona, right? I mean, I'm
excited. I mean, somebody edit that
thing. I mean, is a Mexican guy with
sombrero with me selling tacos. You know
what I'm saying? So, I'm making the
voice and I liked it, you know? I mean,
you're Mexican.
Yeah, totally 100%. I love it. I mean,
talk about tacos and the slang and how
we speak this English. I mean, I love
it. I mean, why not? So, I don't offend
at all. Three people said that that was
a stereotype thing, but when I go to a
Mexican restaurant, I see Mexicans
running it. And if I went to order it,
they're going to come to the door
wearing the uniform and they're going to
be delivering it. And
I don't see how that's stereotype or
racist in any way.
You know, I think racial issues have
always been here.
I think they they were prevalent in
Jesus's day. I mean, he's running around
and like the Jews that were even with
him, the the very disciples hanging out
with Jesus
were like, I don't want to eat with with
that Samaritan over there. Like, no, I'm
not even I'm not even talk to him.
And you know, when Jesus was speaking to
the woman at the well, I mean, they were
baffled. Not only is he speaking to a
woman, which they were prejudic against
the woman, but they were also like,
she's a Samaritan. Has Jesus lost his
mind?
So, this is not like this is not a new
problem. I just I just I feel like
there's something behind the scenes that
is dumping some serious gasoline onto
this.
There there's a couple of issues. One,
there's there's definitely in the past
the way people have been treated
and almost every culture is guilty of
treating another culture poorly.
Almost all of them without exception.
Um you know you have um there have been
tensions between Japanese and Chinese
and Korean. There's been tension between
um European settlers and Native
Americans and and certainly what the the
European settlers did to the Native
Americans, moving them around and saying
you can have this land and not that
land. No way. We want that land now.
We're going to move you. Certainly none
of that was right.
It's wrong. It's wrong.
Um and I think there's been a lot of
pent up frustration from past history.
But the question needs to come and and
it it I think I think it's relevant is
one how many people are still uh putting
that out there and fueling that like do
I think that way today? No, I don't
think that that would that way today.
You know, here I am a a a person who
likely come from some of those European
settlers. Do I think what happened to
the Native Americans was fair? No, I
don't. I'm not the same person that they
were. M
so on one hand it's it's not fair to
continue to hold people essentially
guilty who don't share that same
sentiment
who are centuries down the line
and are not trying to promote that same
sentiment right
and on the other hand I think you have
people who probably still are very
racist
and are still trying to be that way and
and to me that's a case by case you know
basis not not a lump everybody in the
same
you know, vote.
So, what I hear you saying is that an
overgeneralization
about a certain people group or
something, right, that is held
accountable. Oh, because you're white,
you're you the whites have have had
slavery for this long and therefore you
should be punished for this, right?
That's an oversimplification of the
problem and generalizing it on you. So,
the very thing that that people are
screaming out not to happen is still
happening. Yeah,
what happened in the past is is in the
backlash I think happening in some cases
like you know ear early on Europeans
uh and we're talking a long time ago
when they started to discover other
cultures you know if your skin was dark
uh dark colors are evil so you're evil.
Mhm.
Um they they thought themselves superior
in intellect and stuff. And you can find
a lot of this in Freud's writings and
and stuff, you know, like, oh, you're
black, therefore, you know, there's no
way you could be smart and your IQ could
never be as high as the white people.
That kind of stuff. You know, it's like
I know guys that have been brain
surgeons, you know,
has nothing to do with color or race.
Like there there are more geniuses in
China than there are people in the
United States,
right? I mean,
white people are a minority really in
the in the worldwide.
We have to stop pointing the finger at
everybody and generalizing. I think
that's a it's a huge problem and and be
sensitive to what each other are saying.
Right. Right. Listen, I I think one of
the best things and you know the LGBTQ
community has when we've covered this on
this show before, they have requested
strongly requested
uh x amount of percent of every single
film that comes out needs to now have
representation for this demographic.
Why? Because just having that
demographic part of a normal movie is
going to make it acceptable to people,
right?
So I I think that we've got to stop
dividing everybody. That's not the way
for us to get along. We we do need
inclusion. We do need um you know to to
hold together. Now that doesn't mean
that
uh you let down on your moral guard.
Does that make sense? I'm not I'm not
I'm not talking about morality here.
It's like if there's a if there's a
certain people group, regardless of what
color they are, and they're doing
something that you disagree with the
Bible, then you need to
be able to say, "This is what my belief
system is on the Bible." That doesn't
mean don't love them. You need to love
them and still treat them with love and
respect and things, but you don't have
to agree with them and condone it. You
know what I mean?
I want to address preach to yourself.
Thank you so much for your donation. you
I have some good Christian Asian friends
who were always upset with books like
this. Hebrews 13:3, please remember our
brothers and sisters in Korea. And then
I saw a comment that mentioned
that um the depictions of people on
artwork in a restaurant or whatever,
that's their culture. But when someone
who's not of that culture portrays that
same portrayal, it's different.
And they they were they were saying that
that's their belief as well. Mhm.
I don't know. I just that's I that
doesn't really compute with me. I don't
understand.
Probably it probably largely depends on
context. Again, it's like why is Dr.
Seuss doing it? If you find a back
history that he's this racist and he's
putting out propaganda,
then yeah, it's it's wrong for him to do
that. you know, if he's not riot wrong
because
I mean, maybe there are Asians making
the the Disney movie, but
if if this movie was just all white
Disney putting out this movie about uh
Mulan or Mariah,
does that make them racist? Because I
mean, do they have to portray Asians and
well, it must be
current time period. They must be
wearing t-shirts and pants. I mean, I
don't
Well, I I want to get into what I saw
today because an expert has given us the
answer. Uh, if you go to CBC Kids News,
it says, "Six Dr. Seuss books will no
longer be published due to its racist
images. Expert explains why images are
harmful." So, this is from the experts.
Expert in what?
Uh, he he works with minority youths and
things like that and and you know, he's
trying to
battle racismally sensitive. Yeah, he's
a black man himself and he's on the
screen here. Okay, if we can get that on
the screen. So, why are these images
harmful? Says uh Lance Mc mcreddi is his
name. An associate professor and
director at the Ontario Institute
Institute for Studies and Education at
the University of Toronto said these
images are harmful because they draw on
racist stereotypes. According to make
ready, a stereotype is a widely held,
oversimplified, and overgeneralized
belief of a particular person, group, or
things or thing that is simply not true.
This is highlighted here because it's
powerful. He said that stereotypes like
the ones Dr. Seuss uses are harmful
because people end up believing those
stereotypes.
When when a child learns to read and
those reading materials contain
stereotypical images and there isn't an
opportunity for them to actually
interact with the people or groups
they're reading about, then that becomes
how they see these people. McRd said in
an interview with CBC Kids News. McRady
explained how stereotypes of black
people like the image of Africans from
If I Ran a Zoo have affected him in his
own life. When I was in first grade,
I'll never forget when a kid who was
white told me that I was stupid. And
said, and I said, "I'm not stupid. I
know where I come from. I know my
heritage." He said, "Oh, and I said, I'm
not stupid. I know where I come from. I
know my heritage." He said,
and then he said, this is odd here. You
come from mud huts in Africa. You don't
know anything. What that story shows us
shows is that does that student after
viewing so many stereotypical images of
black people really began to believe
that this was not oversimplified but the
black people all just live in mud huts
in Africa said McGreddy.
So it's powerful in the in the pictures.
It's powerful. Yeah. Pictures are
powerful. I I don't just a little book.
I don't think I disagree with that idea
of if you see a picture enough times
over a repetitious lifespan. Yeah.
You're going to have like like I'll give
you an example. Um Eskimos, what do they
look like?
Big furry jackets and a
Where do they live?
An igloo.
In an igloo, right? Every Eskimo lives
in an igloo.
Yeah.
Does every Eskimo live in an igloo? Have
you ever been to Alaska? No. It's a
stereotype. No, it's a stereotype. But,
you know, I've never looked at that and
and thought derogatory towards that
group. You know what I mean? I've seen
it in cartoons. I've seen it in in lots
of different things that, you know, I
think if that's your only context of
what people look like in in Alaska,
that's what you're going to pull from.
Sure. So, I'm
Which is what he's saying. If you don't
have that context of knowing someone,
then this is what you're going to think.
Exactly. So I I don't think I
necessarily totally disagree with what
he what he's doing.
I agree with him.
I don't I don't disagree either. So let
me ask you a question. Have you been
stereotyped?
Have you been stereotyped?
Oh yeah, a lot.
Okay. Have you?
Um yeah, probably. I mean I can't think
of any instance, but
I know I have. And sometimes it's it's a
little thing like I remember um just
something really little like if I would
ever take my glasses off in high school.
I used to get a comment that would be
something like you look smarter with
your glasses on
you know to which my response is oh so I
look dumb with my glasses off you
but it's that idea it's a stereotype
people with glasses on you look smarter
well what makes them look smarter
it's nothing that makes them look
smarter it's you've just known a lot of
people
who you perceived as intelligent and
they happen to wear glasses
I had a friend that wore glasses that
with no prescription in them because he
wanted to appear smarter
yeah So the thing is stereotypes fly
left and right and and what the problem
is really what the big problem is is
emptiness.
Okay. People that are empty,
they try to build themselves up by
putting other people down.
Totally.
And that's what a lot I mean that's just
human nature. That's what it all boils
down to is
I am trying to feel better
than I really feel inside because
there's something inside me that's
missing.
and they're trying a way to fill that
somehow some way. And the only way they
can think of to do it is to put somebody
else down or to make them feel a certain
way by stereotyping them or labeling
them or what have you.
And the problem is I can't change what
you think about me.
Yeah.
But I can change how I respond
to how
to how you treat me.
Yeah.
Right.
Good point.
And I believe that's that's
Christianity. Mhm.
Because I mean they can
look look at Jesus. I mean they will
spit on your face and all stuff. What
Jesus said?
I pray forgiven his face.
Amazing.
Mhm.
Yeah.
So h how as a Christian how we can deal
with this in this society right now in
this culture?
Well, I should let you guys keep going.
I know we got we don't have a limited
amount of time, but I got some Bible
stuff to bring up towards the end. Mhm.
Well, I just think it's interesting that
this guy and and I'm sure there's a lot
of people that agree with him and and
they're saying, "Yeah, we need to get
rid of this stuff because it's affecting
the way people see minorities. They're
seeing them in a different light because
these illustrations, these cartoons,
these muppets or whatever." That's what
we've been saying on this show for
years.
It is just books, man. I mean, what
about movies and videos and music and
clips? and we've actually made a decade
worth of material on this very topic.
So, if you agree with what this guy
says, listen to this concept.
So, when we first started out in our
ministry, um we really wanted to get to
the bottom question of is it just
entertainment?
I mean, I know it's fake. There's no
such thing as superheroes running
around, right? I mean, everybody knows
that. So therefore, it gets dismissed a
lot because it's like whatever, it's
fake. It doesn't it doesn't matter.
But I find it very interesting that a
simple drawing of a China can produce
this kind of an effect. Like we're
talking removing stuff off shelves.
We're talking about you can't sell on
Amazon or eBay. I mean that's
worldwide or maybe I mean the whole
country.
That's a ripple effect on somebody just
going, "Hey, it was it was an image." M
you don't think that a moving series of
images where you're sitting in a theater
staring at a blinking light source for 2
hours and it and have sound and all this
and your brain is in an alpha brain wave
pattern that's not going to affect you
and they talking bad about God.
Yeah. So
this project right here that's called
pseudology was one of the first projects
that we actually worked on in this
ministry and we traveled around the
United States.
English and Spanish.
Yeah. English and Spanish interviewing
neurologists, scientists, doctors,
people. We we actually would email them
from our personal email accounts so that
they didn't have any idea that this was
coming from a Christian perspective
because we did not want them tainted
with this. In fact, some of the people
that we interviewed were downright
against Christianity.
But we said, just getting down to the
science, how much does this affect us? M
and that's why we started looking at the
advertising industry because we're like
hey why does an advertisement work
because it works on familiarity just
like what this gentleman is saying in
this article. If you see an image enough
times you're going to walk away with a
depiction of what that person is like
because you saw that over the course of
time.
Well, what happens if you watch movies
that slam God, slam God, slam God, slam
God over and over and over again? You're
going to walk away with a dislike for
the righteousness that God is asking
for.
We have a trailer for that documentary
right here. I'm going to go ahead and
play that for you guys.
Study found that
40% of three-month-olds are regular TV
watchers.
Would you believe that
of all three-year-olds in America have a
TV in their bedrooms?
No, I can't believe it. It's kind of
disturbing. Everywhere you go, we are
saturated with media. The baby who
watched two hours of TV a day before the
age of three would be 20% more likely to
have attentional problems at age seven.
The frontal lobe of the brain is the
seat of spirituality,
morality in the will. Entertainment
television suppresses the frontal lobe
of the brain.
Humans are particularly visual animals.
What you see is not necessarily
uh a carbon copy of reality. What you
see is a gradual uh coding and
reconstruction of the signal in
neurologic terms and in that process a
lot of interpretation goes on. We have
more depression than ever before in
human history. More anxiety, mental
health problems are skyrocketing
throughout the world and the
entertainment medium is one of the
primary reasons why this is occurring.
More reason to keep infants and toddlers
away from television. Is there a danger
to exposing the mind to realities that
don't really exist?
The bottom line of basically NLP, any
change work, any conditioning, any
brainwashing, it goes down to emotions.
Well, with hypnosis, they're still
trying to find out exactly what the
mechanisms are that are working in the
brain. But now with the neuroscience,
they're really finding out fast. With
neurosinema technology, filmmakers can
now look inside your mind and make
better movies.
[Music]
We're experimenting right now with 30oot
Lamberts in 3D and the result is an
experience that is so close to reality.
It's called Debox and it's set to cause
quite a sensation.
Being tried out at a theater in
Hollywood.
I really enjoyed how it made me feel
like I was in the movie.
You're actually in the movie in the
movie
as if I was in the scene myself.
But the idea of real in cinema as in you
know because Pandora
it's meaningless now.
Exactly. the idea of what's real.
It doesn't take an Einstein, baby or
otherwise, to understand what this
means.
So, back to television, back to the
movies. When you start to have a belief
change or you think it's a certain way,
you say, "Hey, don't watch that or don't
do that yourself." People go, "Nah, they
have reasons a whole bunch of of why
they can't be hypnotized."
Couple seconds.
So, that was the trailer for this
documentary that now is kind of probably
approaching 10 years old. Plus,
that information,
we put a lot of energy and effort into
this one. Um, you know, it it it took us
some time to put it together because we
wanted to do the information justice and
that's why we not only talked about the
science side of what's happening inside
your brain when you when you sit and you
stare at 24 images, right?
I mean, you got to think about that.
That's not just one image. That's 24
images that your brain is imprinting on
that over and over and over again. And
then, you know, after that 2-hour movie
that we we have had seen some quotes
from different um directors of movies
that basically say when you go into a
movie, you come out different.
And think about how many times have you
have you seen somebody go, "Man, I loved
that movie. It changed my life. I mean,
I am a different person because I
watched that movie." Right? Mhm.
But you can't say that the other way.
Like like, "No, no, no, no. I'm not
affected. No, no, no. I can I can play
Fortnite all day long and I can shoot
people and kill them, but it's just a
cartoon."
No, you cannot say that. Everything that
we see, taste, touch, hear, that is
influencing us, putting a mark on our
character, and I guarantee you, you do
that enough times,
it's going to ultimately have an impact
on you.
Yeah. And if it doesn't, then this guy's
a liar. But we agree with what this
guy's saying. Just to just to let you
guys know, I you know, I've seen there
was a couple comments, maybe like three
or three comments or so, where people
just thought that we were ignoring this
thing or justifying it. We're not. We we
are the most diverse ministry I know of.
We got
Mexico, we got China, we had Indonesia,
uh we got Ki from
St. Lucia. St. Lucia. I mean, you know,
we I love the diversity that we have
here and it brings so much to the table.
We have an international channel,
Mexico, you know, Spanish channel. I
love it.
And
and we do try to have a sensitivity to
that because we do approach things
differently coming from different
cultures and stuff and and based on how
you were raised and based on how
somebody else was raised. I mean,
sometimes we even sit around in the
office. I wish we filmed our
conversations in the office. So, just,
you know, put that on YouTube live
because you would really see that that
our end goal is how can we display the
love of Christ.
Amen. and and through all of this junk
that's getting thrown at us. I'm going
to have to agree with with whoever
commented that on there just saying, you
know, one way to stop racism is to stop
talking about it. Levi, yeah, Levi wrote
that, right?
Yes, we should. But also, we need to to
to encourage our brothers and sisters to
link arms with each other, show love to
each other, you know, even when people
are mean and spiteful against you. And I
mean, we've had our our people, there's
people probably on this chat right now
that are just like, "Whatever, these
guys are idiots." And and we've had a
lot of people even say, "You guys make
Christianity look like ridiculous.
You're the reason people reject
Christianity
and we should take you guys out." I
mean, we've seen those comments coming
through and it's like, "Wait a minute. I
hope you're not a Christian saying that
because you know there there's Bible
verses like Corinthians 13. You know
what? You're just a clanging symbol. If
you if you if you know all this
information, but you're not coming at
people with love, then
it's not worth it.
Did you have something else to show?
There is another trailer. Um I don't it
might be shown in here, but I wanted to
ask how is God and Christianity
portrayed in the media?
Wow,
that's a good question. Yeah. If if this
image of a China man has got a book off
the shelf, then what about the Simpsons
who has Ned Flanders and he they're
always making Christianity look like a
joke.
TV shows.
We have a show called Christianity is a
joke. Go watch it. It's got Homer
Simpson on the thumbnail. You'll see
example after example after example of
where God is mocked, Christians are
mocked.
uh they're either portrayed as ignorant
bigots or just geeky, out of touch with
the world. You know,
never in a positive light unless every
once in a while you'll see uh you know a
Catholic priest come in as an exorcist
or something and and you do
how many Christians they watch those
kind of movies and they don't see the
how the
I mean
I mean you bring up you bring up a
really good point. If if the Simpsons
are slamming God like that, nobody's
removing those pieces of media. I mean,
who do I need to call up?
And Christianity is still just a
demographic of people.
We are a minority group.
That's interesting.
Here's another uh trailer showing the
same thing that God is mocked and and
this does change your perspective.
Yeah. I would just say as long as sin
exists,
you will never see fairness and
equality.
That's right. Never.
Yeah. All right, we're going to play
this right here.
What if I told you that God and the
devil made a way for the souls of all
mankind? No direct contact with humans.
That would be the rule. Just influence.
See who would win.
[Music]
This is a spiritual war, not against
flesh and blood, but against
principalities and powers,
against Satan and his evil angels.
All right, let me tell you about your
God's plan.
There is no God. There is no God.
I understand you're not much of a Bible
reader.
God is a miracle. The resurrected the
pig.
Some folks just don't want to go to
heaven.
I think God has sent me a message.
Who are you?
I'm God.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ is a registered trademark
of the Roman Catholic Church.
The world doesn't need a savior and
neither do I.
Got an angel looking after you.
Maybe it's something else.
Tonight we died in hell.
I suddenly had this feeling that
everything was connected.
We're all part of it.
[Applause]
Are we ready for it?
It's not really coming soon, but ago
very old.
Yeah, that coming soon was like 2008.
Coming soon. Yeah, it it's very
interesting because um you know I I when
I studied film and stuff in school, I I
learned how to edit barely. And actually
what really taught me how to edit was
working for this ministry in the very
very beginning. Um this was probably one
of the first few things that that I ever
actually cut.
And I cut it on um yeah, it was on
iMovie. I just didn't have any tools to
do it really and uh to kind of see how
it's progressed from here. But you guys
get a sense of what's being said. I
mean, over and over and over again, the
overarching theme of of Hollywood has
traditionally been to make fun of
Christianity, stereotype it, they're the
crazies, they're the ones that are like,
you know, uh if you don't follow their
rules, you're just going to be um
killed. And it's just a wrong depiction.
Not every Christian is like that. Yes,
there's some that are, but not everyone
is like that.
So, wanted to read something. Um, but
before I do, I'm just going to say, you
know, I recognize probably when I was an
early teenager, I used to be bullied and
made fun of a lot that
it would consume me if I just allowed
myself to hate those people or let them
get inside my head.
And I just had to tell myself, I don't
care. Don't care what you think. you
know, it's not going to change me. It's
not going to change who I am. It's not
going to change how I approach. It's,
you know, and I'm gonna stop like being
antagonistic
in my mind towards those people. Um, if
I hadn't have done that, I would just
probably be this really super angry
hater person today because of the way
people treated me.
And I I like this verse in the Psalms.
It's in Psalm 119. I think it's 165 that
says, "Great peace have they that love
thy law and nothing shall offend them."
I try to live by that. Like, yeah, the
world is always going to bring all kinds
of things towards you to offend you.
But if I put myself in God's hands and I
say, I want to focus on what you have
for me to focus, then all these other
things aren't going to offend me.
They're not going to bother me. I'm not
to say that I'm not going to be
concerned um or that I'm not going to
think certain things are wrong, but I'm
not going to let it um get to me,
you know.
And so I want to read something from
Titus chapter 3 says, "Remind them to be
subject to rulers and authorities to
obey, to be ready for every good work,
to speak evil of no one, to be
peaceable, gentle, showing all humility
to all men. For we ourselves were also
once foolish, disobedient, deceived,
serving various lust and pleasures,
living in malice and envy, hateful and
hating one another. I mean that sounds
like our world today, right?
And it was the world then. Why? Because
the world hasn't changed.
Yeah. Interesting.
And what has to change is us.
So as Christians, you know, here Paul is
writing and says, "You were these
people. You're not those people
anymore." That's right. You're going
through a change. He continues, "But
when the kindness and the love of God
our savior appeared to man, not by the
works of righteousness which we have
done, but according to his mercy, he
saved us through the washing of
regeneration and renewing of the Holy
Spirit, whom he poured out on us
abundantly through Jesus Christ our
savior, that having been justified by
his grace, we should become hes
according to the hope of eternal life."
We have a better home, a better future.
uh we have you know we have a direction
that God has laid out for us and that
direction is to approach other people in
love. You know be considerate to other
people to be sensitive to other people
and I also believe to not be easily
offended by what the the world throws at
us. You know Jesus said the world hated
me.
They're going to hate you. You for my
name's sake.
It's going to hate you too. And in this
world, we should expect that those
things are going to come our way. But we
should find our peace in the prince of
peace
and not be so easily shaken or
disturbed. Are these things disturbing?
Yes, they're disturbing.
Mhm.
But we have to learn to be very solid in
Christ, knowing that it's only going to
get worse from here.
It's not going to get better.
Yeah.
And we're going to have to develop, you
know, thick skin, but high toleration
and love for other people. Mhm.
I like that because and it seems like in
today's society at large, Christians are
the ones who are most tolerant of this
type of thing right now because like we
just saw, we're constantly being mocked
and ridiculed and God is being portrayed
in a bad light and yet you don't see us
pulling movies and stuff.
Well, if they weren't, what would that
say to the world?
Yeah.
You know, it's it's if we're going to
truly say that we're Christians, we need
to respond that way. We we can't be like
throwing the hate back and you know
tearing them down
tearing people down and and responses
Jesus. But even if that happens because
a very small select group of people, you
cannot lump everybody into that category
just because one group of people over
here. Because think about how the devil
works, right?
He's going like, "Oh, wow. If everybody
thinks this, this of this group, well,
I'm just going to make one or two people
over here go and, you know, do some
really bad stuff to people and then
they'll think the whole group's like
that." You know what I mean? And so
there's extremism that that is spawned
out of that and and retaliation and this
and that, but not everybody's like that.
And I I totally agree with you, Keith. I
think that the approach to this is we
have to be able to to,
you know,
take whatever is being thrown at us and
flip it around and love them back.
Love them back.
I see somebody in there in the chat just
said, "Especially when my family has a
history of being victims of genocide."
Wow.
I mean, there are cultures who have gone
through that. I can only imagine.
Yeah. I mean, I have no
I've read stories
context of that. I I wouldn't even know
how to how to handle that, you know, as
far as I've just read it as well. And
so, you know,
it's only the grace of God, I think,
that brings you through something like
that.
That's right.
And only the grace of God that will
bring us through what lies ahead.
That's right. True that.
So I guess you know I just I hope that
you guys are getting a blessing out of
this because
I we we wanted to start up and open up
this conversation just to basically say
look uh
you are affected by what you see.
You're affected by what you listen to
the music and everything, right? You
know if if if Cardi B is on your top 100
list, right? I mean, you're gonna be
influenced by that type of of thing or
either letting your guard down over here
or something like that. So, you know, I
I hope that you you hear coming out of
our ministry time and time again, be
careful little eyes what you see. You
know, be careful little ears what you
hear. like like don't voluntarily put
yourself in front of so much evil all
the time because it's proven it's a
proven fact that you can manipulate and
influence and change someone's mind
based on media.
Just as this guy was saying, the expert
in this. Uh just to share a little
little secret with you guys because it's
official now. We're going to be doing a
show with Holden Hardman next month,
right? So it's going to be cool. um
we're going to be talking about this
kind of stuff and because there's people
that say why don't you get an unbiased
opinion have somebody on the panel that
doesn't believe like you guys so that'll
that chance will happen in April 8th I
think.
So I also want to speak to this real
quick um because we hear this a lot. You
guys are crazy on the internet and and
you know we can't we we we don't know
what you're saying and this and that and
you're making Christianity look bad.
But, you know, try to appreciate when
somebody has a difference of opinion to
be able to just appreciate, hey, that's
your that's your choice. You you can
believe like that. I don't have to
necessarily believe like you, right?
Give people the freedom and the space to
be able to talk and stuff that without
just hating on them, dogging on them,
and and you you never know. I mean, I'm
I'm kind of hoping what comes out of
this conversation with somebody who
clearly does not think like us and share
the same ideas but calls himself a
Christian and we are Christians, you
know. So, I think that there's some way
that we can at least sit down and
discuss the topic,
have a healthy dialogue back and forth,
not just
I'm going to make a video against what
you said. And, you know, there's no
there's no opportunity to get to respond
to what you said, I'm going to respond
to that. You know, it's just this long
video. So, I think it'll be good, you
know.
Cool.
Well, check out our YouTube video called
Is Christianity a joke? And then also if
you guys want to check out Sudology,
it's one of my favorite documentaries.
This one in Replacement Gods. Uh if you
know somebody who's not a Christian or
maybe uh I don't know, this is the first
way to really show somebody that media
does affect you whether you're a
Christian or not. And it's just the
scientific aspect. And if you can
understand this and you believe this,
then you have to question what am I
putting into my brain? What am I putting
before my eyes all the time? And and you
have to understand that it is
influencing you because the science
proves that way.
Yeah. But a little Spanish.
And I think it works the other way as
well. The more that you spend time in
your Bible, the more that you you read
about the stories of Jesus, you're
you're keeping your eyes focused on
Jesus, right? The more you're going to
want to become like Jesus. That's just
how it works. wherever you're putting
your attention. So, if your attention is
a whole lot more on Hollywood than it is
on Jesus, then I'm going to bet there's
things in your life that are probably
going to be leaning one way or the
other, or you're going to be accepting
things that that you probably otherwise
wouldn't have accepted. So, just keep
that in mind. We're not telling you like
you just have to like, you know, you
can't watch anything and turn it all off
and this and that. Um, you know, there
are certain things that that you can
watch that will be edifying to you. Um,
we're not giving you a list because we
don't want to just sit here and, you
know,
give you a list of everything you can
and cannot watch. We're teaching a
principle for you to learn. Does it
speak according to the word of God? Yes
or no? Because if it doesn't, there is
no light in it. That's exactly what the
Bible says.
Test everything through the word of God.
And and if it holds up to that, then it
could be profitable.
Grace uh says that I will put LED videos
before my eyes.
Praise the Lord. That's great. A lot of
good comments from you. Thank you for
your encouragement. We need that
encouragement. You know, we're we're on
the front lines of this battlefield out
here in this spiritual war. So, we hope
you guys were blessed by this show. We
we love the the chance to get to You
wanted to watch the other one?
Yeah. Let's let's throw in one more just
so you can see an updated version of of
some of the content that's coming out
here because uh we we've done this for
so long that you can just see the
pattern. And that's the purpose of
showing you this is really that this is
nothing new. It's been going on for a
long time. It's still going on and it's
getting worse and worse and worse.
That's right. We're going to play this
right now.
Many things over many lifetimes
Krishna Yahweh.
God is tribal. God takes sides. No man
in the sky intervened when I was a boy
to deliver me from daddy's fist and
abominations.
I figured out way back. God is all
powerful. He cannot be all good.
You are a king. You lived in a cloud
city, but evil forces came and cast you
out.
Consider the possibility that God does
not like you. He never wanted you. In
all probability, he hates you. That's
not the worst thing that can happen.
It isn't.
We don't need him.
We don't agree.
We are God's unwanted children. So be
it.
All around you are spirits. Child,
I
cut you off.
I always like to think of it as I got
him sitting there. Whip a little message
at him. Whip a little moral at him. Whip
a little of what my view of the world is
because that's what every good filmmaker
does.
[Music]
And this was a story about Christ. It's
all about sacrifice. The world I hear
their cries. So what happens? He gets
the knife in the side and later he falls
to the earth in the shape of a crucifix.
You're my savior man, my own personal
Jesus Christ.
It's very, very destructive in pretty
much every facet of your life.
Wherever this being was, he always had
four followers he would imbue with
power. Like the four horsemen of the
apocalypse. Got that one from the Bible.
Well, the Bible got it from him.
You will never see anyone argue with
their television set when entertainment
television is going on. They're not
going to argue with the set cuz they
don't have the ability.
[Music]
Yes.
Yes. He did say Yahweh. It was a very
blatant attack on God. Thank you so
much, Levi, Faith White. need, man. You
don't know how much we appreciate your
support like this. We can't do this show
without you guys. And so, um, let's know
that this, like, like Scott was saying,
this is just getting worse and worse,
man. We're we're doing the anime
documentary. And
yeah, I mean the the last one for that
documentary has been taking a little bit
of a while because
the way that it ends is so
in yourrface disturbing because this
whole entire war in heaven started over
the Ten Commandments. And that's exactly
how this latest anime has gone. It's
just a direct attack against the Ten
Commandments. And you know, it it's it's
alarming and it's scary. And once you
once you throw that out, you're going to
see if if there is no moral line right
there. And everyone has to make up their
own morality based on whatever they
feel, this place can get very dark very
fast. And that's exactly where we're
headed in a speeding train. So pray for
us. Pray for us that that that project
really illustrates a a uh a really
wakeup call. Yeah, it's got to be a
wakeup call. Christians, we're making a
call right now. It's time to wake out of
our sleep and open our eyes to the
spiritual warfare that is around us. And
and brothers and sisters, this this has
been going on for a long time and it's
getting intense because I believe that
our savior is coming soon and we will
see him in those clouds very soon. So,
we want to be right. We want to be
clothed with his garment of
righteousness, not our own because it's
filthy rags. We want his righteousness
and we want to put our eyes in front of
things that are righteous, not evil.
We cannot do it on our own strength. It
has to be Christ living through us. And
that's why in the last days, there's
going to be a lot of people who have a
form of godliness, but they're denying
the power, the power that Christ gives
you to live inside you and to to help
you to overcome sin. That's his strength
and that's the power that a lot of
people are rejecting these days. That's
right.
Yeah.
You got something there, Alex? Yes, I
just want to let you guys know if you
have some friends or family members or
maybe you're uh speak Spanish right now.
Just want to let you know that Sudology
is available in Spanish with over 40
plus voiceovers. It was a lot of hard
work uh over eight months of working
bringing a documentary. A lot of people
they think well why is not a new
documentary? It takes time, it takes
effort. uh we need to bring I we uh we
didn't want to just put a subtitles you
know we want uh bring you know with the
voiceovers so it takes time but I just
want to let you know that it's available
in espanol
so go check it out and support us you
know in little studios in Spanish too on
uh in our YouTube channel
the English version is actually
available on Amazon Prime we don't
really promote that that much but we're
we're getting stuff on Amazon Prime as
well
you can also uh rent it from digital
download on Vimeo so email. Yeah,
there's another way you can watch it.
So, we're trying whatever way you guys
want. We want you to see this
information. So, we're trying to put it
out there for you. So, thanks.
Awesome. Somebody wants us to turn to
Orthodox Christianity.
All right. We love you guys so much. We
We like that we have this opportunity,
the technology to share this live, like
right when we see stuff while the
topic's still hot and not two weeks
later. And we really appreciate your
support. We appreciate the chat. We see
it right in front of us. So, thank you
for uh chatting with us and we will see
you Friday. We love you. God bless you
guys.
Bye.
[Music]